В Україні почали діяти пільги на ввезення
електромобілів. Як заявив міністр
інфраструктури України Володимир Омелян,
завдяки скасуванню з першого січня ПДВ
та акцизного податку на ввезення автівок
з електричними двигунами електрокари в Україні
стануть одними з найдешевших у Європі.
У Міністерстві інфраструктури прогнозують:
без податку на додану вартість та акцизу
як нові, так і вживані електрокари  подешевшають
на 17%. І так буде протягом усього року.
Державна фіскальна служба вважає, що
ціни для автоімпортерів знизяться навіть на 20%.
Взяти для прикладу найпопулярнішу в Україні
електроавтівку Nissan Leaf 2017 року з батареєю
у 30 кіловат-годин. Нова така буде коштувати
від 660 тисяч гривень. Або 20 тисяч євро.
У Європі автодилери виставляють вищі ціни.
Так, в Норвегії, яка є світовим чемпіоном
з розвитку електротранспорту, ця ж модель коштує
від 25 тисяч євро. Приблизно стільки ж -
у Великобританії і Франції. В Австрії - понад 30 тисяч,
а в Німеччині - від 31. У Чехії - 28,
а найдешевше, схоже, купувати в Португалії -
там новий Nissan Leaf віддадуть за 22 тисячі.
Проте остаточна вартість покупки для мешканців ЄС
буде значно нижчою, адже майже в усіх цих країнах
існують державні програми, які пропонують
податкові знижки або субсидії
на купівлю електроавтомобілів.
Найщедріша Франція, де держава може докласти
до 10 тисяч євро.
Німеччина гарантує 4 тисячі євро на придбання
електрокару і 3 тисячі - на гібрид. Половину субсидії
сплачує уряд, іншу половину - автовиробник.
Ціна електроавтомобілів у Європі,
враховуючи знижки та преференції,
виявляється цілком співмірною з Україною.
Про кардинальну різницю в ціні, принаймні
нових автівок, говорити не доводиться.
А враховуючи низьку купівельну спроможність
українців, електромобілі є, навпаки,
одними з найдорожчих у Європі. Проте пільги
на імпорт електрокарів, безперечно,
є позитивний кроком для розвитку
екотранспорту в Україні.